the noke boys are one of the hottest
groups on the internet and they continue
to grow a massive online following they
recently went to mar-a-lago and they
interviewed former president donald
trump and during that interview they
talked about everything from world war
iii to putin to what's going on here in
the united states today president trump
said multiple times that he thought that
the interview would actually be taken
down by youtube and now it looks like he
ended up being right one of the tweets
that we have is from kyle fulgard who
went ahead and said youtube has deleted
our trump episode that over 5 million
views in 24 hours the communication from
youtube doesn't give us much more
information it simply says that their
team reviewed the content and
unfortunately they think it violates
their misinformation policy well whether
you think it does or not you probably
should actually have an opinion does it
or does it not it's a pretty big deal to
take down an interview with over 5
million views in 24 hours the former
president of the united states talking
about things like his relationship with
vladimir putin who happens to be
invading another country right now or
war iii and the potential use of nuclear
weapons or other things here in the
united states like the economy or
inflation and so ultimately what we are
watching is censorship and all sorts of
decision making that's happening inside
these big tech companies but nobody
knows exactly how it's being done who's
involved who holds them accountable why
is it that we think that some big
technology company they know what's true
and what's not at one point they were
telling us not to wear masks then they
were telling us to wear masks and over
and over and over again over the last
two years at one point they think
something's true at another point they
don't if you believe in free speech the
true test of free speech is to protect
the speech of the people you disagree
with this whole idea of misinformation
is ridiculous we then see donald trump's
son go ahead and say that after the
deletion he thinks that they should put
the podcast up on rumble video which is
another video platform which is
promising that they won't be censoring
speech that they won't try to become the
arbiter of truth and ultimately that's
what's going to happen in the free
market is that if the existing systems
continue to censor people if they
continue to kick content off of their
platforms ultimately somebody's going to
build a competitor because the people
want access to information they want to
go straight to the source why is it that
the big technology companies there's
just some employees sitting there saying
i like this i don't like this i agree
with this i don't agree with this i
think that's true i don't think that's
true that's a scary place to live it's a
slippery slope and one we should be
aware of now donald trump came out with
a statement by the 45th president of the
united states of america he said
whatever happened to free speech in our
country incredibly but not surprising
the big tech lunatics have taken down my
interview with the very popular milk
boys so that nobody can watch it or in
any way listen to it 24 hours that was
up it set every record for them by many
times interestingly on the show i told
them that this would happen because big
tech and the fake news media fear the
truth they fear criticism about biden
and above all they don't want to talk
about the rig 2020 presidential election
all topics discussed in russia the
people are not allowed to know that
they're fighting a war with ukraine
that's where our media is going and
that's where our country is going
because it quickly follows just study
history are we going to allow this to
happen our country is going to hell now
of course if you think about this
there's some truth in everything that's
being said here but also it's being said
in a bombastic way and so whether you
believe what is being said or whether
you completely disagree with it i don't
want to live in a world where large
technology companies get to be the
arbiter of truth and if you go back in
history there's literally fake news
being printed on pieces of newspaper
that sit at the grocery store line it's
called tabloids and so ultimately
misinformation fake news whatever you
want to call it has been around for
centuries somehow now though these large
companies are deciding what gets to be
said and what doesn't they're private
companies they have the right to do that
i just think that they're going to run
into some trouble when all of a sudden
the competition shows up and says we're
not gonna play that game hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time